the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi in the reading assignment for today
you will notice in the textbook that the
topic is double integrals in terms of
polar coordinates now the trouble with
polar coordinates is that aside from
straight lines there perhaps the only
coordinate system that we've studied in
terms of Euclidean geometry in our high
school class and consequently if we were
to have a change of variables other than
straight linear changes of variables or
polar coordinates it might be difficult
to geometrically try to determine what
the new double integral looks like with
respect to the new variables the text
you may recall when you are not you may
recall you haven't read it yet but when
you read the text you'll notice at the
end that professor Thomas says there is
a technique called the Jacobian
multiplying by the Jacobian determinant
that tells you how to transfer a double
integral from x and y coordinates into
another coordinate system at any rate
with that prologue as background our aim
in today's lecture is to show more
generally how the Jacobian sneaks into
the study of multiple integrals in
particular we call today's lecture
multiple integration and the Jacobian
and by way of review let me pick a
problem that we've solved in the past in
great detail but perhaps from a slightly
different perspective that will lead
into where the Jacobian matrix and the
Jacobian determinant comes from recall
that when we wanted to compute the
definite integral 1 2 3 to X square root
of x squared plus 1 DX we made the
substitution u equals x squared plus 1
or inverting this x equals positive
square root of u minus 1 and I emphasize
the positive to point out that in
general the inverse of a squaring
function is not one-to-one see a square
root is usually double valued but notice
that with the restriction that X must be
on the interval from 1 through 3 X
cannot be negative and therefore we
certainly can assume that locally
meaning in the region in which we're
interested in that X is the positive
square root of U minus one from this we
saw that D U was 2x DX we then went back
to this equation here we replace 2x DX
by its value D u we replaced the square
root of x squared plus 1 by the square
root of U and then noticing that when X
equaled 1 u equal 2 and when X equal 3 u
equal 10 we wound up with the fact that
the number named by this definite
integral was the same as the number
named by this definite integral now the
only thing that I'd like to say here as
an aside is the following there is
sometimes a tendency to think of DX as
just being a symbol over here that we
think of it as saying all we want is a
function whose derivative with respect
to X is this and other than that it
makes no difference what we put in here
what I would like you to see at this
time and our to review at this time
because we know what happens is that if
we made the substitutions mentioned here
forgetting about the DX in other words
if we replace X by the positive square
root of u minus 1 if we replace x
squared plus 1 by U and if we replace
the limits 1 to 3 by 2 to 10 and then
just tacked on the D U to indicate that
we were doing this problem with respect
to U the resulting definite integral
would not be equivalent to the original
one that is not to say that this
couldn't be computed what I mean is this
number is incorrect if by this number
you mean the value of this definite
integral here and notice that from a
pictorial point of view all we're really
saying is that the integral that the
integral 1 2 3 to X square root of X
square plus 1 DX is the area of the
region R where R is that region in the
xy-plane bounded between the lines x
equals 1 x equals 3 below by the x-axis
and above by the curve y equals to x
times the square root of x squared plus
1 and have
simply put the values of these endpoints
in here namely when X is 1 Y is 2 square
roots of 2 when X is 3 y is 6 square
roots of 10 to give you sort of an
orientation of this particular curve on
the other hand that other integral that
was incorrect integral from 2 to 10 etc
is the area of the region s where s is
the region that's obtained by taking
that interval from 1 to 3 along the x
axis mapping it by u equals x squared
plus 1 in other words it goes from 2 to
10 and in fact you have to know that all
I'm saying is if we just read this thing
mechanically and the y u plane this
would be the area of the region s where
s is bounded vertically by the lines X
equal u equal 2 and u equal 10 below by
the U axis and above by the curve y
equals twice square root u minus 1
square root of U and it should be clear
by inspection that there is no reason to
expect that the area of the region R is
the same as the area of the region s
even though both R and s have areas now
what the whole geometrical impact is on
this technique of integration techniques
of integration what the whole geometric
impact is is this this is a difficult
integral to evaluate to find the area
hopefully one would hope that we could
find a way of scaling an element of area
here to correspond to an element of area
here which was easier to compute and
that since the mapping was one-to-one by
adding up the appropriately scaled
pieces here we equivalently add up the
pieces to find the area of the region R
now because I know that that sounds
vague to you I am going to do that in
much more detail for the time being let
me point out though that if I want to
view this as a mapping the interesting
thing is that any point on the x axis
maps into the corresponding point on the
U axis by the mapping
you equals x squared plus 1 but it's
important to point out that the values
of x and u were not independent they
were chosen to obey the identity of the
u equals x squared plus 1 or X is the
positive square root of u minus 1 so
what that means geometrically is that
whatever height was above a point in the
region are along the x axis whatever
height was here that height is the same
when that point is moved to the region s
and because that again sounds like a
difficult mouthful let me write that all
I'm saying is notice that for the U
corresponding to a given x - x times the
square root of x squared plus 1 is equal
to 2 times the square root of U minus 1
times the square root of U how do I know
that well I know that because I picked X
to be the square root of U minus 1 or
equivalently what u equals x squared
plus 1 this says that I can replace X by
the square root of u minus 1 this says I
can replace x squared plus 1 by U
consequently as long as the X matches
with the image u this number is the same
as this number in other words again in
terms of a picture if I start with the
point on the x axis x equals 2 and I'm
looking at the point P being the point
on the region I directly above x equals
2 since 2 gets mapped into 5 by the
mapping u equals x squared plus 1 c2
squared plus 1 is 5 what was the height
that went with the point 2 over here the
height that went with the point 2 over
here was simply what four square roots
of 5 and I claim that that's the same as
this because when X was 2 U is 5 this is
2 square roots of 5 5 minus 1 is 4
square root of 4 is 2 this is 4
therefore 2 times 2 4 square roots of 5
it makes no difference whether you're
using the X or the U but that the point
keeps the same height it shifted
laterally but it does not distort the
height which means now if we want to
view this not as a mapping
from X Y plane into the UI plane but
more traditionally in terms of the XY
plane into the U V plane that's what
this V is in parentheses here it means
that I might want to name the y-axis the
V axis just so that I can use my
identification established in the
previous block in our course when we
talked about mapping the XY plane into
the UV plane that is not an accent mark
over the V that just happens to be an
interruption of this arrow that connects
two to five but at any rate in terms of
mappings notice that the region R is
mapped onto the region asks by the
mapping U equals x squared plus 1 and V
equals Y in other words u equals x
squared plus 1 but the y coordinate is
the same as the V coordinates just
changing the name of the axis here to
correspond to the UV plane and now the
idea is simply this since at least in
the domain that we're interested in the
mapping new equals x squared plus 1 V
equals y maps are on 2's in a one-to-one
manner each increment of area Delta a
sub s matches one and only one Delta a
sub R let me give you an example of what
I mean by this let's suppose I start
with the region s and let me arbitrarily
divide it up into a number the interval
from 2 to 10 into a number of pieces
here oh I guess in the diagram that I've
used here I've divided this up into four
pieces all right so I get these four
little rectangles an approximation for
the area of the region s would be the
sum of the areas of these four
rectangles what I'm saying is that under
our mapping these four regions induce
four mutually exclusive reach regions
that cover all of our in fact since V
equals y the way we do this mechanically
is for example let's focus on just one
of these little elements over here let's
suppose I want to find how to match this
shaded rectangle with a suitable
rectangle of our what I say is whatever
the V value is over here it must be the
same as the Y value of the point that
mapped into this point on the axis in
other words if I call this point here u
zero that comes from some point here
which I'll call X zero
so u zero comes from X zero what must
the height above this point be since the
transformation does not change the Y
value at all since V equals y what this
means is I can now draw a line parallel
to the U axis here come over to here and
that locates where on the curve I'm
going to locate the point x0 C in other
words I just come across like this
either of these two ways I this is how I
locate the x0 that matches the u0 I take
its height take that same height over to
this curve and project down notice of
course that the Delta X that measures
the difference between these two points
on the x axis is not the same as the
Delta u that measures the distance
between these two points but what I want
you to see is that these four rectangles
here induce four rectangles here and
what I would like to be able to do is
somehow be able hopefully to find out
how to express a typical rectangle here
as a scaled version of one of these
rectangles hoping that when I then take
the sum the resulting summation leads to
an integral which is easy to evaluate
and before I get into that to show you
what that's happened here I think I'm
making this longer than it may really
seem but let me just get on to the next
step let me what I want to do next is to
blow up these two shaded areas so I can
look at them in more detail what I have
is a region which I'll call Delta a sub
s in the uv-plane and a Delta a sub R in
the XY plane where the mapping is again
what u equals x squared plus 1 V equals
y this piece matches with this peach
piece all right now for small Delta you
notice that by definition of the
Delta X divided by Delta U is
approximately DX to you consequently I
can say that Delta X is approximately DX
D u times Delta u now the thing that I
really want is not the area of a piece
of s
I want a portion of the area of our I
want Delta a sub R notice that Delta a
sub R has as its height Y sub 0 and as
its width Delta X notice also that since
V sub 0 equals y sub 0 see y equals V in
this transformation notice that the area
of Delta the area Delta AR is V 0 times
Delta X ok we also know that Delta X is
approximately DX the u times Delta u so
making this substitution I see that my
little increment of area in the region R
is precisely what it's V 0 times the
replacement for Delta X DX D u times
Delta u let me also notice that the
region Delta a s over here has as its
height V 0 as its base Delta u so the
area of this rectangle is V 0 Delta u
let me therefore group these two factors
together rewrite this term in this
fashion noticing that V 0 Delta U is
Delta a sub s and I now have the very
interesting result that Delta a sub R is
not Delta a sub s but the correction
factor is what its DX tu multiplying
Delta a sub s with for the sake of
argument over a small enough strip here
let me assume that I've chosen DX to you
to be evaluated at U equals u 0 say at
any rate what we are saying is to find
all of the area of region R we want to
add up all of these Delta a sub bars as
the maximum Delta X sub K goes to 0 but
we've just seen a typical Delta a sub R
is a DX - u evaluated at U equals u 0
times Delta a sub s and there
define Delta a sub R this limit is
precisely the same as this limit now the
point is that Delta a sub s is certainly
just as messy as Delta a sub R in
general it may also happen that when I
scale Delta a sub s by multiplying it by
DX to you the result is even more messy
than the original expression but it's
also possible that the xdu happens to be
the factor that wipes out the nasty part
of Delta a sub s you see what I'm saying
is if if there is a one-to-one
correspondence which there is between
the Delta a s's and the Delta a R's if
this expression here happens to be
convenient I can find this area simply
there was this sum simply by computing
this sum and that's why in techniques of
integration that's precisely what we
look for we look for the change of
variable the substitution that makes
this thing simplify and that's precisely
what happened in this particular example
keep in mind that what I've written down
over here is true for any substitution
where X is some function of you not just
for x equals u squared plus 1 I could
have done this anytime but what I claim
is that if X weren't equal to this to
what was it the square root of u minus 1
this wouldn't have turned out to be a
very nice expression and you see this is
going to be called the one-dimensional
Jacobian later on this is the correction
factor the scaling factor you see let's
see how that that worked out notice that
Delta a sub s was V 0 times Delta U and
notice that by definition of what the
curve looked like in the uv-plane V 0 is
twice the square root of u 0 minus 1
times the square root of u 0 on the
other hand what is DX d u since u is
equal to x squared plus 1 it's easy to
show that the XD U is 1 over twice the
square root of u minus 1 so in
particular when u equals u 0 DX D U is 1
over 2 square root of u 0 minus 1 notice
now even though Delta a sub s is quite
messy when I multiply it by this
particular scaling factor look at what
that scaling
acta wipes out the to square root of you
0-1 wipes this out all I have left is
the square root of u 0 times Delta u
when I formed the definite integral
summing this thing up it's trivial you
see to see that that simply comes out to
be what the definite integral from 2 to
10 square root of u do u and since this
particular sum was equal to a sub R that
is the mapping interpretation of Y the
area of the region R can be evaluated by
this particular integral now in a sense
all of this has been review even though
the pitch has been slightly different
let me now generalize this to a bonafide
mapping of two dimensional space into
two dimensional space and the reason I
use the word bonafide is that when you
say let u equal x squared plus 1 and let
V equal Y you really haven't got a
general mapping of two dimensional space
into two dimensional space you've
essentially let the y axis remain fixed
so let me talk about something more
general let's suppose I have an
arbitrary region R and an arbitrary
function f bar which maps are onto s in
a one-to-one manner by the way notice
the whole idea is this
when I want the area of the region R
it's going to involve a DX dy inside the
double integral when I want the area of
the region s that's what's going to
involve a Delta u times Delta V now the
reason that Delta u times Delta V is
indeed a bonafide element of area when
we're breaking up s lies in the fact
that in the uv-plane Delta u times Delta
V is the actual area of an increment of
area in s when we break up s by lines
parallel to the U and V axis on the
other hand notice that if we see what
the line u equals a constant comes from
back in the xy-plane U as a function of
x and y and to say that U of XY equals a
constant does not mean you have a
straight line you can have some pretty
squiggly lines over here in other words
it might be a very funny-looking line
that maps into a straight line a
straight vertical line in the uv-plane
with respect to the mapping f bar and in
the similar way the lines v equal a
constant the lines v equal constant in
the XY plane I read what V of X y equals
a constant that's a general curve in the
XY plane
what we're saying is that since this
mapping is one-to-one when I break up
this region into elementary elements of
rectangles that will induce a breaking
up of this region into little elements
here but notice that the resulting
elements say we take a piece like this
and we see where that piece comes from
let's say that that particular piece
happened to come from here say that was
the one-to-one correspondence
notice that you can't shed you can take
Delta u times Delta V here but notice
that Delta u times Delta V simply means
multiplying two edges which aren't
straight lines which aren't necessarily
perpendicular and hence in no way should
represent what the area of the of this
little element here is the key point is
we do not want the area of the region s
we want the area of the region R and
what we're hoping that we can do is that
by making the change of variables that
map's the region R in the XY plane into
the region s in the UV plane that we
somehow find a convenient way of scaling
an individual element of area here with
respect to one here and then to find the
area of this region by adding up the
appropriate pieces here and again let me
show you what that means in terms of
just an enlargement again you see in the
same as I did before let me take this
little piece over here and really blow
it up let me take this little piece that
is the back map of this in other words
the piece that maps into this let me
blow that up and the idea is this if I
pick Delta U and Delta V sufficiently
small notice that the area of the back
map of Delta a sub s is approximately
the area of a parallelogram you see come
back to this statement
after I've explained the picture what
I'm saying is I start with an element of
area Delta a sub s in the uv-plane you
see I pick its vertices I'll call them a
bar b bar d bar C bar that's a little
rectangle over here
because the mapping is one-to-one I know
that there is one and only one point in
the XY plane that maps into a bar so
that let's call that point a there is
one and only one point in the XY plane
that map's in to B bar let's call that B
one of the only one point in the XY
plane that map's in to C bar let's call
that point C and let me leave the point
D out for a moment now the idea is if we
call the coordinates of a bar use zero
comma V zero then because this is a line
parallel to the U axis call this
dimension Delta u B bar is used there oh
plus Delta u comma V zero C bar call
this dimension Delta V is U 0 comma V
zero plus Delta V now the point is there
is no reason why the image of B bar name
of the point B has to be on the same
line parallel has to be on the line that
joins a parallel to the x axis in other
words B is up here someplace
C is up here someplace in other words
again there's no reason why these back
maps give me a rectangle over here the
point is that B has some coordinates
it's x0 plus some increment involving X
let me call that Delta x1 and its
y-coordinate is y 0 plus Delta Y 1 C is
the point X 0 plus some into the
increment Delta x2 comma y 0 plus Delta
Y 2 and what I'm saying is now if I were
to just look at the parallelogram which
had a B and a C as adjacent sides it's
very easy for me to find the area of
that parallelogram namely to find the
area of a parallelogram in vector form I
just take the magnitude of the cross
product of the two vectors a B and AC
you see what's wrong with this is that
that particular parallelogram is not the
exact image of the back
of Delta a s-sure a bond maps exactly
into a c ba maps exactly into c b ba
maps exactly into b but the point is
that these points along a bar C bar do
not map into the straight line from A to
C in general in other words what
characterizes this this is characterized
by delta u equals 0 and written that
when u is written in terms of x and y
that doesn't say that Delta X or Delta Y
is 0 so the true image of this might be
what I've represented with this dotted
array here knows what the true back map
of Delta a is is this dotted thing where
D is now this vertex here you see
there's no guarantee that the back map
of D bar is going to be the fourth
vertex of this parallelogram but what
the key point is and this is where that
linearity is so important is that if the
transformation is smooth enough
continuously differentiable then what it
does mean is that as long as Delta U and
Delta V are sufficiently small the true
area of the region Delta AI that we're
looking for is approximately equal to
the area of this parallelogram and by
approximately equal I mean what that the
error goes to zero as we take the limit
in forming the double sum those again
the key map that the key point is this
the back map of Delta a sub s yields
Delta AR but that Delta AR is
approximately this parallelogram and the
area of this parallelogram is exactly
the magnitude of a be the vector a B
crossed with AC in other words the
approximation comes in because this is
exactly the area of the parallelogram
but Delta a sub R is only approximately
equal to the area of the parallelogram
at any rate notice in terms of I and J
components how easy it is to compute a B
and a C you see one of the components of
the vector from A to B the I component
is Delta x1
see this - this the J component is this
- this right AC in other words AC has
where's its components it's this - this
namely Delta X - this - this is the Y
component that's Delta Y - in other
words to write this out so you don't
have to listen to how fast I'm talking a
B is this particular vector AC is this
particular vector remembering that when
we take a cross product I cross I is
zero J cross J is zero I cross J is K
and J cross I is minus K remember for
the cross product we can't change the
order of the terms from the order in
which they appear we then determine what
that a B cross AC is Delta X 1 Delta Y 2
minus Delta X 2 Delta Y 1 times the
vector K the unit vector in the Z
direction now Delta X 1 is exactly C
member we're looking at the
parallelogram which is a straight line
if you want to think of it in terms of
the region R by differentials Delta X 1
would be what it's approximately the
partial of X with respect to u times
Delta u plus the partial of X with
respect to V times Delta V similarly
Delta Y 1 is y sub u times Delta u plus
y sub V times Delta V but now keep in
mind where Delta X 1 and Delta Y 1 come
from Delta X 1 and Delta Y 1 comes from
the back mapping from a bar b bar back
to a B and along a bar b bar notice that
V is always equal to V 0 so that means
that Delta V is 0 that means therefore
that because Delta V is 0 Delta X 1 and
Delta Y 1 I simply this C this drops out
similarly Delta X 2 and Delta Y 2
come from the back map of a bar C bar
along a bar C bar u is equal to u 0 so
Delta U is 0 so writing this out these
drop out and now with these terms being
0 with these terms being 0 I can very
simply compute the product Delta X 1
Delta Y 2 minus Delta X 2 Delta Y 1
and if I do that you see right away what
I obtain is what it's this times this I
now okay
collect the terms here in other words I
want the Delta U and the Delta V
together the multiplier outruns here is
X sub u times y sub V in a similar way
Delta X 2 times Delta Y 1 is X sub V y
sub u times Delta u Delta V therefore
the putting that into here the magnitude
of a B cross AC is simply this
expression here noticing that the K
vector drops out because its magnitude
is 1 notice that Delta u times Delta V
is precisely Delta a sub s and that X
sub u times y sub V minus X sub V times
y sub u is precisely the determinant of
our old friend the Jacobian matrix the
Jacobian matrix of X and y with respect
to U and V in other words Delta a sub R
is approximately equal to the
determinant of the Jacobian matrix of
excellent y with respect to U and V
times Delta a yes and if I now perform
this double sum you see this becomes
what the area of the region R let's
write that and that's really the area of
the region R is a double integral over R
DX dy and that's the same as what the
double integral over s times D u DV
multiplied by the scaling factor of the
Jacobian determinant by the way notice I
dropped the determinant symbol over here
the reason for that is that many
textbooks including our own use this
notation not to name the Jacobian matrix
but to name the Jacobian determinant I
have been using this to name the
Jacobian matrix from this point on
I will now switch to become uniform with
the text and unless otherwise specified
I will write this rather than put the
determinant symbol in from from now on
in our course when I write this I am
referring to the Jacobian mate
okay but the thing is this notice that
the given mapping
might straighten out the region our into
a nicer looking region s but to offset
this it may also turn out that the
resulting integrand here is much worse
than the integrand here here the
multiplier of the x dy was the simple
number one wasn't it here was
multiplying the UDV no matter how nice s
is is this expression here which may be
quite messy and therefore in most
practical applications where one solves
multiple into integrals by a change of
variable one not only wants a change of
variables that straightens out the
region into a nicer looking one he wants
a combination of two things he would
like a nicer looking region and more
importantly even if he can't get a nicer
looking region at least if he gets a
correction factor a Jacobian determinant
that gives him something that's easy to
integrate he'll settle for that and what
that means hopefully will become clearer
as we go through the exercises and the
reading material at any rate i think
that's all i want to say about a
supplement to Professor Thomas's
treatment of polar coordinates at this
time and until next time then goodbye
funding for the publication
of this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate